- The former district attorney
in the Ahmaud Arbery case
has been indicted on
a count of obstruction
and a violation of her oath.
I really didn't see this one coming.
This all relates to
ways that she allegedly
mishandled the case of Ahmaud Arbery,
who was pursued in
gunned down while jogging
through the Atlanta suburb.
The former district
attorney actually recused
herself early on because one
of the alleged gunman
was a former government employee.
And charges were only brought
by the Georgia Attorney General
two months later after cell phone footage
of the shooting
was released to the public.
The indictment says
that former D.A. Johnson
violated her oath by not disclosing
that she had tried to
appoint D.A. Barnhill
to the case after she recused herself.
When she recommended
that Barnhill be appointed
by the Attorney General.
An indictment also
states that she knowingly
and directed two police
officers not to arrest
the alleged gunman,
which apparently gives rise
to a potential obstruction charge.
This is absolutely wild and comes
out of left field,
so we'll see everyone in court.